recycling as a game and a chance to
practice
for nine-year-old valeria yapzeva it's
like a guessing game plastic or paper
is this paper
no it's plastic
twice a week valeria comes to the young
naturalists club today the kids are
talking about how to protect the planet
from garbage the lesson plan came from
germany it's part of a german russian
pilot project on sustainable waste
management
[Music]
we need to do our best for the planet
because it gave us life
recycling isn't so hard
and it's better to put a bit of time
into sorting your waste then regret it
later
valeria and her best friend varvara live
in the ramonski district in the south of
russia the district is home to more than
30 000 people in various villages
it's in one of three pilot regions for a
german russian recycling project the
german agency for international
cooperation the giz worked with local
authorities to come up with a waste
management concept here around 50
recycling bins have been put up since
last year soon there will be over 200
across the district
at first people weren't used to these
bins we carried out an information
campaign in the media and social media
about recycling
now the bins are filling up more and
more
after the morning's recycling efforts
valeria and her friend need a snack
there's a lot to take in
they tell valeria's mother yulia
ryatsova about what they learned
when you don't have recycling bins you
just throw things away
but when you sort your waste you have to
think where does this go
it's like a game your brain has to work
hard
by recycling we give objects a new life
for now there's no recycling facility
outside the apartment here but since
last year valeria's family has several
bins under the sink for plastic paper
glass and non-recyclable waste
valeria's mother admits that it was her
daughter who won her over to recycling
she said mom we learned something about
garbage we shouldn't throw everything
out together in one pile we should sort
our waste of course it all starts with
individuals people who've decided to
recycle but for now saying the whole
country is going to start recycling is
maybe a little bit too optimistic
[Music]
[Applause]
but the russian government is pushing
for change in part because garbage dumps
have sparked protests in a number of
regions in shias in the north of the
country people demonstrated for several
months against a planned landfill site
in 2019 the government introduced a plan
to implement country-wide waste
management system by 2024. there are
sorting facilities like this one in
every one of russia's regions now but
how much of the trash will actually be
recycled remains to be seen many
recycling and waste to energy plants
have yet to open experts say russia is
on the right path but has a long way to
go
in russia we have ever more packaging in
our household waste the amount doubles
every two years
in the past consumers were usually
buying for big families
now there are more one-person households
so there's more individual packaging
another reason for the new generation to
rethink like these third graders in the
city of novovaronias are learning to do
around 2000 local children have learned
how to protect the planet from trash in
green lessons run by the german russian
recycling project
we're trying to use education and
engaging material to create a new
awareness
a new kind of person who has a
responsible attitude towards waste
management
surveys show that at least 70 percent of
russians are willing to sort their waste
if the recycling bins are right outside
their door
here in novovaronish some neighborhoods
already have plastic collection
containers and more german bins will
arrive soon
now that we have these plastic
containers we sort our trash when you
relax at the river here you can see how
much plastic is in it it's a disgrace
i do it for a cleaner environment
there are no recycling bins in our
courtyard yet everything's just thrown
in a big pile that's bad we want bins
too
valeria and varvara know that some trash
can be recycled even without the bins
barvara has a compost heap in her
family's garden up to 70 percent of the
garbage here in this rural district is
organic waste
soon this will turn into fertilizer for
flowers trees and for new vegetables
when we grow up we have to parcel this
on to our kids too
otherwise they'll just make a mess again
but i hope that people will listen up
now and start recycling because it's
really easy
the two girls hope that other children
will also think twice and join them in
trying to make the environment and the
planet a little bit less polluted
you